Politicians do seem to give off a slimy feel.
Everything about them is polished and tailored
to try to get my vote.
It’s kind of gross.
And yet, I still vote for them.
From the way they look, the way they sound,
to the words they choose.
Politicians and their staffs carefully craft
their speeches and appearance to invoke emotion
in their constituents.
Emotion plays a huge role in who we will vote
for.
A study published in the journal Psychological
Review found that often, our moral judgements
aren’t the result of reasoning but of quick,
automatic, intuitive feelings.
And politicians can use this to their advantage.
They often get your vote by evoking some strong
emotion in you.
Emotion tends to call people to action more
than reasoning, and unfortunately, the emotions
political candidates often invoke are anxiety
or fear.
A study published in the journal Political
Psychology, found that anxiety tends to influence
our political views, especially towards certain
groups.
For example, anxiety may make some people
remember negative experiences with immigrants
making them more likely to vote for a candidate
who advocates tighter immigration policies.
Plus, anxiety causes people to see ambiguous
information in a more negative and threatening
light.
And by invoking fear, politicians can rally
people around specific causes and create stronger
allegiances with those we consider like us.
Even more than what politicians say, is how
they say it.
They might change the way they talk.
A study published in PLOS One found a deeper
voice correlates with the idea that the politician
is stronger, more competent, and older.
But deeper voices only benefit politicians
in specific instances.
For example, a study published in the journal
Political Psychology looked at the 2012 U.S
House elections, and found if a politician's
voice was deeper and their opponent was a
female, they were less likely to win; especially
if they were male.
The researchers think that a lower voice might
seem too aggressive, in that case.
But it’s not just the language politicians
use, and the pitch of their voice, it’s
their body language too.
Politicians need to project an image of calmness
and surety.
They use “positive body language” like
keeping gestures below shoulder level and
steadying their hands.
According to Don Khoury, a nonverbal communication
consultant: if politicians sway or fidget
too much, this gives off vibes of arrogance,
insincerity, or low confidence, which turns
off voters.
Some researchers even believe they can predict
election results on body language alone.
And looks do go a long way.
A study published in the journal Science found
that voters often judge the character of a
political candidate based entirely on their
visual appearance, which can have huge impacts
on elections.
So politicians try to appear as attractive
as possible, especially if they’re a woman,
because studies show that not only do people
prefer better looking politicians, they actually
get more media coverage.
And a study published in the journal Social
Cognitive and Affective Neuroscience found
that a negatively received image, like if
they appeared threatening, was far more detrimental
to their campaign than being attractive was
helpful.
So much of what we feel about politicians
and politics is so... subconscious.
Your feelings are decided before you even
know it.
But maybe once we start to become more aware
of political tactics, we can use our cool
reasoning instead of our fiery emotions to
pick the next president.